sagi javid says he wants covered
restrictions to end as soon as possible
to limit the damage to the economy but
whilst he is the new health secretary
the numbers haven't changed infections
are still
rising over 22 000 recorded today
but crucially only three deaths we know
over the weekend there are some delays
in reporting and a technical issue
meant some cases were missing from
yesterday's tally but what the health
secretary will be hoping
is the link between cases
hospitalizations and deaths
is finally breaking here we have the
seven day average of infection rates
versus hospitalizations it's the average
so a bit lower than the number we've
seen today but you can see
how each are growing but importantly
hospitalizations aren't climbing as
fast as cases now if we look at the
growth rate for each over the last
fortnight
by the 19th of july we could see over 45
000 cases a day and hospitalizations
could reach 566 a day
even if cases were this high as long as
the hospitalizations were low
we could still unlock the success of the
vaccine rollout though is
key to breaking that link boris johnson
set new vaccine targets to be achieved
by the first of july the offer of a
first dose to
all over 18s and two-thirds of adults to
be double-jabbed
this data matters because while
restrictions on businesses remain for at
least another three weeks
support starts being withdrawn this week
on july the first the furlough scheme
that guarantees employees
80 of their wages becomes less generous
the government will pay
70 and employers 10 employer pension and
national insurance contributions will
also increase
not only that though vat deferrals also
end
meaning businesses will have to start
paying the tax once again albeit at a
reduced rate of five percent
but business rates exemptions and bounce
back loan repayments will also
be due all at a cost to businesses
unable to fully reopen
which is why it matters what step four
on the roadmap looks like
in reality this is what the government
said would
happen indoor gatherings nightclubs even
travel all reopening without
restrictions
these sectors say any continuation of
social distancing or mandatory
certification
would be a hammer blow
every day that these businesses are left
in restrictions are trading
below profit for trading at a loss means
that there is a greater likelihood of
business failure
so every day is a cost we have to wait
and see what the scientific evidence
suggests
but you've got over two thirds of the
population now
double jabbed 80 to 90 moving towards a
single jab
that should give us confidence that we
can reopen the economy
the treasury where sajid javid was
briefly the boss says its current
measures are sufficient to prop up the
economy but businesses are
adamant if the state extends
restrictions it must also
extend support